all this on the day we have to say
farewell to the trumps
melania trump came out she gave a
farewell address first
it was very sad to see this i love
melania trump she is the most elegant
first lady we've ever had she makes
everyone's heart a pitter patter
my wife will send me videos of melania
speaking just saying oh michael oh my
gosh
my heart's melting you know she just
walks out she's so composed so beautiful
she said something that i i think it's
it's worth thinking about as we enter
the biden administration
not because it's any groundbreaking
statement not because it's even
objectively true but because it
describes
the current political situation melania
trump says be passionate
in everything you do in the midst of
hardship
we have seen the best of america shine
through
students have made cards and delivered
groceries
to our senior citizens teachers
have worked twice as hard to keep our
children learning
families have come together to provide
meals
supplies comfort and friendship to those
in need
be passionate in everything you do but
always remember
that violence is never the answer
and will never be justified
okay objectively what she's saying is
not true
right even she says violence is never
the answer well violence
was the answer uh in war wasn't it when
when war is declared on us
certainly we would all say the answer to
that is violence not just to roll over
right was violence the answer in world
war ii that seems to be the only
historical reference point that anybody
has
everyone's always comparing everyone
else to the nazis or whatever but okay
let's use it
was violence the answer in world war ii
uh probably it was right
you know if someone is some madman is
trying to conquer the whole world then
violence is the answer to that
it's never justified no it is justified
uh saint thomas aquinas and many many
other thinkers have discussed
when it is justified i think what
melania is saying here is that unjust
violence is not justified
you know sort of vigilantism or
riots everywhere or looting or whatever
of course that's not justified that's
not justified at all
and probably this is a reference to the
capitol hill riot sure it should also
be a reference to blm fair enough and
then she says be passionate in
everything you do well there's some
places where you you know
a little detachment is fine too but i i
don't mean to nitpick
the first lady's speech because i think
there's actually some
real wisdom in here
what we have had if nothing else for the
past four years
is passion it's why
an unusual coalition of voters came
together and sent trump to washington in
the first place
it's why people have had so much fun
over the last four years
is we had passion and it seemed like for
the first time
in my life we had passion from
the the white house obama in a way
you know had a little bit of passion but
obama was speeding things up in a little
bit of way but it was all still the same
kind of liberal establishment
and maybe clinton bill clinton advanced
that
a little more slowly and bush a little
more slowly and obama a little more
quickly it was all the same thing
it was all the exact same thing it's all
the same kind of platitudes and the same
kind of
dull bureaucratic technocratic language
and then trump comes in like a wrecking
ball
and that really fired a lot of us up and
we thought that was oh there's actually
some hope
that we can avoid this kind of bizarre
insane
ugly anti-american technocratic malaise
and we got that with trump and now
trump's leaving
it's very sad trump giving his farewell
address
wishing joe biden well my fellow
americans
four years ago we launched a great
national effort
to rebuild our country to renew its
spirit and to restore the allegiance of
this government
to its citizens in short we embarked on
a mission to make america great again
for all americans as i conclude my term
as
the 45th president of the united states
i stand before you truly proud of what
we have achieved together
we did what we came here to do
and so much more this week we
inaugurate a new administration
and pray for its success in keeping
america safe
and prosperous we extend our best wishes
and we also want them to have luck a
very
important word so he's going out on a
sort of nice gracious note okay
biden's coming in we've accomplished all
we wanted to and much much more
there's some things obviously the trump
administration didn't accomplish but i
will
say uh without a doubt he's uh the
favorite president of my lifetime
and and he he talked about the same sort
of thing we've been talking about all
day that
this doesn't neatly cut across into our
politics the trumpet the trump
administration
was unique in our normal political
regime he says it's not about left or
right it's about doing good for the
american people
together with millions of hard-working
patriots across this land we built the
greatest political movement in the
history of our country
we also built the greatest economy in
the history of the world
it was about america first because we
all wanted to
make america great again we restored the
principle that a nation exists
to serve as citizens our agenda was not
about
right or left it wasn't about republican
or democrat
but about the good of a nation and that
means
the whole nation with the support and
prayers of the american people
we achieved more than anyone thought
possible
nobody thought we could even come close
you know i usually don't like this
rhetoric of it's not about left it's not
about right
it's not red america blue america right
obama's said similar things
but the reason i don't love that even
the country over party or whatever these
other slogans is because
you join a political party to help your
country the idea is this party is going
to help the country more so i'm going to
join that and support it so i think it's
a little bit of a false dichotomy and
the trump administration's been
generally very right-wing with some
exceptions
but it is worth pointing out he was a
little different he wasn't the usual
republican
he cracked that status quo
for a little bit in part of cracking it
was he won he got a lot of things
accomplished at least the first time
then we had a pretty strange 2020 pretty
strange november of 2020
and that's that's the end of the term
farewell to
the best president of my lifetime i hope
president trump stays
around as a voice in politics i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show to check out the full
episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts